emocratic presidential candidates had their
final debate last night for four Saturdays,
South South Carolina
primary, and then also the last debate before
Tuesday's March 3rd super Tuesday, a contest,
which will include maybe enough primaries
to really get a definitive sense of the path
forward for this nomination.
Could Bernie get 50% plus one?
Is it more likely that there will not be any
candidate getting to that threshold or far
less likely, but still possible will some
other candidate get to 50% plus one before
the convention.
Now, I'm not going to do a full review of
the debate last night with a whole bunch of
clips because quite frankly, it was very similar
to last week's debate except with worse moderation.
It was again, this kind of ultimate fighting
type debate with many candidates coming in
and we knew they would do it going after Bernie
Sanders, who's now the presumptive front runner.
Uh, the moderation was absolutely atrocious.
People constantly talking over each other.
That applies both to multiple moderators talking
at the same time while multiple candidates
talk at the same time, uh, cutting people
short of their 75 seconds.
But at the same time letting some candidates
go too long.
It was a complete and total mess.
But the overall assessment of what went on
last night for me is that Joe Biden came in
with a bunch of energy.
He didn't say anything different, but he at
least looked more energetic than he has before.
Maybe he would get himself a small boost.
The crowd was not particularly friendly to
Bernie and there's a backstory there as well.
Um, a lot more booing of Bernie and cheering
of Joe Biden and Michael Bloomberg, and that's
not reflective of anything other than the
people that got seats in that room.
Some of them paying quite a bit in order to
be in that room.
I don't think anybody really did particular
damage to their own campaign.
I don't expect polling to move very much.
I think if anything, Biden may be gets a slight
boost because he just seemed more alive last
night.
But it's important to know, and we're going
to get to the polling data later.
As bad as Michael Bloomberg's performance
was in last week's debate, Bloomberg was totally
unaffected in the polls.
He did not drop in the polls after last week's
debate.
So by showing up last night and being slightly
prepared, like I don't think Michael Bloomberg's
responses were great yesterday.
And in fact he had some atrocious responses,
which we will talk about.
I don't think that Michael Bloomberg is, um,
uh, going to see any decline in polls.
And in super Tuesday polls, he's actually
doing okay, which is why I want to focus on
this next clip.
Michael Bloomberg had an unbelievable Freud
and slip last night where he was defending
his support of Democrats historically.
And the reason he was doing this as he was
attacked by some candidates, including Elizabeth
Warren, of supporting Republicans, basically
saying, this guy's really a Republican.
It's not really a Democrat.
Michael Bloomberg was prepared and he fought
back by talking about all the money he's given
to Democrats, including many Democrats who
won races in the 2018 midterm.
And he slipped and said that he had bought
members of Congress and immediately caught
himself mid sentence.
We noticed the Freudian slip live during our
stream before the stream was shut down, which
I'll talk about a little bit later.
Let's take a look at the clip.
Here it is, the height of oligarchical nonsense.
Michael Bloomberg, admitting that he bought
members of Congress and then realizing, I'm
not really supposed to be saying that.
That's not what I'm supposed to be saying.
Take a look.
The all of the new Democrats that came in
and put Nancy Pelosi in charge and gave the
Congress the ability to control this president.
I, I, I got them.
Number two,
I bought her I, I got them and I tweeted about
this right when it happened saying Bloomberg
Friday and slip there.
Almost said he bought the current Congress.
Anyone noticed that?
And indeed people did.
Woke up to a whole bunch of articles about
this this morning.
Some of this stuff is just poetically perfect.
Like it's almost too perfect.
Where if you wrote in a screenplay about this
primary and said, here's an idea, let's have
the super rich guy slip and catch himself
saying he bought the current Congress.
Nah, it's too farfetched.
It doesn't make we keep, we can't include
that in the screenplay.
Nobody would believe it.
This is actually more than just Bloomberg
being mostly a Republican or mostly a Democrat.
Bloomberg is much like many of these rich
guys in that he is someone who funds both
sides, huge corporations and a lot of these
rich guys don't just fund Democrats or Republicans.
Some rich guys just fund one side.
That's true, but a lot of these rich guys
will fund both sides so that when they need
someone here or they need someone there, they
have them available at their Beck and call.
Bloomberg has supported many Republicans and
he supported many Democrats.
He's been a Republican and he's been a Democrat.
Trump was a Democrat for a lot of his life,
ran for president as a Republican because
that's where he decided he would be able to
win or potentially win a nomination.
Bloomberg has been an important funder for
many Democrats and now he himself is running
for president.
Yeah.
Bloomberg got caught here saying the quiet
part out loud, but it's the same thing Trump
said during his debates with Hillary Clinton
that yeah, he's made donations and he's smart.
He knows how to play the game.
He knows how to use money in order to get
what he wants from politicians.
This is the game.
Bloomberg and Trump play the same game.
The difference is Bloomberg has way more money
with which to play it.
Even buying ads during the commercial breaks
of last night's debate.
People like Trump and Bloomberg, their politics
are different.
They're very different, but Trump and Bloomberg
see the world through dollar signs.
What will it cost me to buy this or that?
What will it cost me to buy this or that person?
You can buy stuff, supporters, friends, loyalty
institutions, whatever you want.
That's fundamentally what this is about, what
they each plan to buy is where they differ
and certainly on their politics.
They also do differ, but a wacky and wild
evening, including Michael Bloomberg, saying
that he bought the current Congress, which
if you're already the guy buying his way onto
the debate stage and into probably a bunch
of different delegates in different super
Tuesday States, that's not what you want to
be caught saying.
Let's now talk about the polling and super
Tuesday.